attention gamers yes sir i installed the
new assassin's creed valhalla on all
your computers shout out to ubisoft for
sponsoring this video
and i gave you each papers with
instructions i can't read
first person to beat all three raids and
the epic boss wins ten thousand dollars
for their grandma
yes grandma three two
one go how do you sprint use the link in
description to pre-order assassin's
creed valhalla
right now i'm taking a boat to the very
first rate because i gotta win 10 grand
for my grandma grandma this is for you
screw your grandma jimmy screw your
grandma i have a strategic advantage
easier to raid at night i took over the
boat
let's go everyone yo i'm right at sunset
and this is
gorgeous i can rain i'm raining i'm
raining me and the boys are gonna raid
the first place so
we have three raids then the boss and
you win
they're ganging up on me it's a 2v1 i'm
using my mid as fodder go you guys go
first oh oh oh i'm throwing axes
all right get out of here get out of
here yep sorry goodbye
goodbye oh my god you can throw the axes
as you can tell by what i'm using here
dual loading weapons adds for versatile
and different combat fbi open up
oh in the monastery bye for my grandma
oh get off my troops that's right good
job boys let me join in
okay you're done you're done bro yeah
hubble next to the mouth i'm about to
die i have half health i need some
backup
i'm approaching the first raid challenge
you haven't even started the first raid
yet dude they're just singing on this
boat and playing an acoustic guitar
oh watch out bro hit the heavy attack
oh oh my gosh i just stuck a sword
through him
sky attack oh my gosh she did not see
that one coming
raid oh the horn has sounded
we're opening a gold casket right now
grandma is that you
raid complete i finished my first raid
let's go grandma
stop moving you're not allowed to move
until you call your grandma
i don't have my grandma's phone number
grandma please don't answer
it's for your own good hello i'm doing a
challenge can you wish me luck
on it oh i pray hard yes all right i
love you
there i called my grandma if she doesn't
answer it's fine grandma come on
fix your phone wait are you calling your
grandma chandler's competing for ten
thousand dollars for you in a gaming
video what
if i win i you get 10 grand all right
now i'm allowed to move you can win 10
000.
my grandma won't pick up can you pretend
to be my grandma
thank you on to the second raid let's go
i'm flanking i'm flanking
ethan your grandma can wait bro you
don't know how old she is she may not
have time
bro hurry up more raw materials for carl
oh they're going inside
heavy attack heavy attack this water is
so beautiful i'm popping you guys wait
please wait for the next raid everybody
i don't think that's how that works carl
hope i'm about today i'm about to i'm
about today i'm about to let me out let
me out let me out let me out
oh right through the chest i see the
marker second rain is about to begin
as you can see assassin's creed valhalla
is set in a beautiful 9th century
england and it's a dark age open world
let's go
i hope we set it all on fire take their
stuff force open this casket dude all of
my passengers are going to get so
seasick it's actually unreal
i just killed this man with his own
spear oh and he's stuck in the ground
what this came running out the door
this guy's trying to open the gasket and
i won't help him and he's just
struggling
all right we're just gonna run away hey
you guys handle that
ah i just completed the second raid
let's go
uh you finished the second raid i
finished the second raid and there's a
donkey running away with a bunch of
supplies
time to raid these nimrods let's row the
boat a little bit come on
stop lacking let's get to that third
raid baby wait
it's like they all turn up as soon as i
hit the raid button assault is really
cool because it's when you and your crew
get together and you just take over a
huge fortress
it allows for consistently epic battles
let's go
oh god i'm so sorry i didn't mean to
climb on you how do you do a ue in a
boat
oh what a slave come on out water's fine
guys water's fine gentlemen oh no
the last raid's 1600 meters away carl
are you at the second radio i am jimmy
chandler are you at the second
raid yes sir dang it i'm in last place
i'm on my way to the third one
let's push this open raw material yeah
no i'm gonna crash i'm gonna crash
rating the third place let's go
sound the horns is that guy got such a
long pole bro
wait i could put my hood on and look
really cool while raiding i just look
like a big burly man now oh i'm gonna
shoot this chicken why are you bullying
me
it's like the boss his name's yao min oh
i just stabbed the almond with his own
sword oh hey guys mind if i
oh sorry by the way settlements like
this are upgradable and will be your
main base when playing the game
stop why are you such a you're a
slippery snake you know that
i don't know how you guys got to the
second raid so fast it's like five
million miles away from me you have to
raise your sails when you're in the boat
as well it makes you go faster you have
to raise your mom
raid complete go to the raid killaball
second raid complete all right you guys
will be happy to know i'm at the second
raid there's a guy with a hammer should
be building houses not attacking me
all right next stop third raid open this
door right now
somebody help me oh oh there's a boss
there's a boss i'm not prepared
all right we're on the right path to
success more enemies you gotta be
kidding me how many people live here
help me why are you standing there i'm
trying to win
i thought they were playing country
music for a second all right this has to
be it's a castle
you're all three on the third raid i'm
on the third raid i already finished the
third raid i'm better than everybody
else i'm just kidding i haven't finished
the third grade i lied
well i have a confession what is your
confession i don't actually have a
grandma
what so you lied to us i did so who are
you gonna give the money to dude how are
you even born well i had grandmas but
oh so anyways i'm just gonna quit you
guys are way far ahead i'm gonna
spectate
get him get him get him let's go finish
i'm finally opening the case
that you just finished the third i just
finished the third all right i'm gonna
go check on the voice
ethan please stop lying i'm not lying i
did it it's honestly embarrassing either
just chill ethan god
all right how are you doing oh watch
this oh check me out check me out here
let's get this guy come on you're my
best friend oh wait a book
book of knowledge new ability let me see
what this new ability is
what okay i gotta use that i'm about to
raid this ice village
i better get a pet penguin after this go
go go go go
ethan did you ever consider thinking
about their grandmas not at all actually
mine's more important understandable ow
i'm on fire
i just want to kill you guys did you
hear what ethan just said
no he said his grammy is better than
yours
are you gonna stand for that carl yes
shut up are you gonna just let him trash
talk your grandma who said that what
what
he said his grandma's better at what
being old
no no no she's better at bingo than your
grandma that's for sure well my
grandma's in indiana and my grandma wins
like every week so
boom can't do this alone wow nice
nice this guy like fakes opening the
door
then i brought you a stale half-eaten
grilled cheese sandwich epic i'll give
it to you but only if you just you know
let them catch up a bit should that be
nice and do that i feel like my grandma
you took it all right do i have to eat
it no i just wanted to give you a stale
half eaten okay i'll keep it in my mouth
for good luck
let's go oh i'm hot i'm hot i'm hot
i'm hot i'm really hot oh god i'm so hot
i'm all fine
guys guys guys guys don't worry i gave
him a stale happy
grilled cheese sandwich hey i bought you
guys like five seconds
that's all i'll need give me four
where's the firework
it's not working ow oh i'm gonna die i
just died what a nerd he died
i blew myself up okay i have to restart
the raid all over again no
yes ethan is at fault and he's behind he
just died that's your chance to catch up
that's all you have to do to get in
wait how'd you get in there already and
you didn't even tell me wagon
yeah final raw materials i need for this
raid and then i'm on to the final boss
and ethan's gonna die like seven more
times so i got all the time in the world
grandma this is for you blow up that
wagon yeah uh oh hey jimmy what does
this say
raid complete wait is that the third
raid no all i got is the final one
i wanted my grandma buddy get in get in
get in get in get in again
boys sell harder for my grandma let's
see if i can scare ethan
oh we're preparing
it scared me so bad i was trying to
scare you
scared the crap out of me
sound the horn gentlemen it is time all
right we gotta kill the final boss let's
go man
yeah ethan if you kill that boss your
granny gets 10 granny
i'm shooting you in the face for my
grandma
yup yup yup yup we're blowing up the
compound oh no he grabbed my face
and he just had button killed me wait
where'd the smoke grenade come from i
thought we were in the 1930s
burning this guy alive for my grandma
please please i beg of you please
this is for my grandma what if he just
doesn't care about your grandmother
ow this man has a oh no you're done
wait i didn't die we're in like a bear
pit now he's so close to death
look at his health oh no he had one
sliver now
huh i just laid out dead watch over the
propane
that's right that's right grandma you
want 10 grand cause i'll give it to you
yeah no he got it no no you didn't no
no you did it ethan who was subbing in
for chris because he's on vacation
just won his grandma ten thousand
dollars i want you guys to hug him
yeah if you liked what you saw in this
video assassin's creed valhalla will be
available on november 10th and thank you
so much ubisoft for sponsoring this
video use the link in description to
pre-order assassin's creed valhalla
right now